to go with my gut - listen at my inner
easting my instinct I mean it's really
true and that's why I hit the heart
moment out there because when I look
back over my life I wrote a book a man
writing the book called woman Thou Art
Loosed two women at a time no publisher
wanted to publish it
there was no precedence for it but I
went with my gut and that book saw seven
million copies bless people all over the
world been translated into ten different
languages if I would have gone by the
empirical data I would have never done
it every move from Charleston West
Virginia to Dallas Texas didn't even
know anybody but I felt like I was
finished in West Virginia instinctively
saw Dallas as a place that I needed to
be and I went from pastoring a thousand
people to 30,000 every major moves that
ever happened in my life from doing
gospel place and turned into movies that
ended up with contracts with Sony's and
I've never been trained to do it it was
all instinct and when I presented this
this idea and begin to talk about and I
started talking to other people like
Tyler Perry or Oprah Winfrey or
or anybody else and I got a chance to
corner long enough to ask a question or
two they were instinctive - thank you
guys so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed I'd love to know what you think
of the video leave it down in the
comments below I will join the
discussion thanks again for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon